one of the viewers pointed out not
incorrectly that one definition of
return on asset so this whole video is
going to be on return on asset that one
definition of return on asset and I if
you look it up on some of the finance
Isis Finance sites or even some finance
textbooks they'll tell you is
net income net income over total assets
which is different from what I told you
and other sources and namely Wikipedia
will tell you that it is actually so
this is one definition of return on
asset another definition is net income
I'll just abbreviate that as n dot I net
income plus interest so they're adding
back your interest and then they're
subtracting out the tax savings due to
interest minus tax savings due to
interest tax savings from interest and
we could do a whole video on the tax
savings from interest and when it makes
more sense to raise money with debt
versus equity because of the cost of
interest but that also increases your
chance of bankruptcy the more debt you
take on well do we could do a series of
videos on that but tax savings from
interest divided by assets this is the
definition that Wikipedia gives you and
then I gave you my very first definition
I gave you was operating profit
operating profit over assets and then
I'll add one more definition to this
video just because I think it's worth
talking about it I think this is kind of
a general theme in finance is that
there's all these formulas for things
and people you know memorize them and
but in the process you lose a lot of the
intuition and it's also important to
realize that there are multiple ways of
defining the exact same term so people
can confidently say oh they're ROI ROA
is this and you know what it's never a
bad question to ask them what they mean
by ROA and I think you'd also be
surprised by how many people won't be
able to tell you what they mean by ROA
but the last one if I have time to go
over we'll call it e bit I know that
looks like a very strange word
EBIT divided by assets but just so you
know what EEB it is EEB it is just
earnings before interest in taxes so
this is just the same thing as income
net income plus interest plus taxes so
it's kind of a pre-tax pre-tax ROA
divided by assets so these are all
different things and you might already
say wait if I took net income let's
actually talk about this for a second
let's compare a bit to operating profit
you might immediately say if I took net
income so a bit let's remember a bit
it's just an acronym for earnings before
interest in taxes so let's see if our
earnings are $350,000 and we were to add
back the taxes in the interest we add
back the taxes gets us to pre-tax and we
add back to the interest we get to at
least in this example we get to an
operating profit number so you might say
why is there a different term EEB it
instead of one of the people just always
use operating profit and the reason why
there's a different term is sometimes
you can have non operating profit so
let's say that out of this 10 million
dollars of assets that I didn't go there
in the first example because I didn't
really want to complicate the issue but
I'll complicate the issue a little bit
now let's say out of this nine let's say
out of this 10 million dollar of assets
let's say that nine million dollars
let's say that nine million dollars are
kind of operating assets there the
enterprise they're the things that are
needed to generate the operating profit
and then you had another 1 million
dollars of assets that of this 10
million that is just you know the
company really doesn't need it to
operate they just have it around maybe
they're speculating on oil prices or
they're just hedging something or
they're they just have a super flush
bank account so these assets might be
generating non operating income so you
could say you could you could have a
line here for interest income or
investment income we put that investment
income and then the company might have
made some money there might have made
eight I don't know might make $10,000 on
investment income and of course that'll
drop to this line this will then become
five hundred ten thousand the taxes will
be one hundred fifty three thousand and
the net income is what like one three
hundred and fifty six thousand or
something along those and actually three
hundred fifty seven thousand because you
have a 30 percent tax rate now that
makes sense right I added an extra ten
thousand dollars of income here and at
the end of the day you're going to tax
at a thirty percent so it should be
seven thousand dollars more of earnings
so that makes sense three fifty seven
thousand dollars but this is the
difference between operating income and
EBIT EBIT in this case would be the
operating profit plus this investment
income so II bit in the case that I just
added some investment income would be
you know 1 1 million 1 million ten
thousand dollars while operating profit
would be 1 million dollars I didn't want
to go there in the first video and
that's why I just said operating profit
divided by assets but if you really
consider all of the assets and if you
assume that there are some assets there
that are non operating but they're just
they're not really used to make widgets
or to sell widgets or marketing widgets
or or help the CEO in any way kind of be
do his job or her job then you look
whatever this generates is actually non
operating income and so II bit factors
that in so even I kind of view it it
goes backwards it starts with net income
and then it adds back the taxes and
interest while operating profit you
start at the top line and you go down
but in general if you take a bit and you
take out the non operating income you
get back to operating profits so that's
what II bid is right here and so you can
already imagine that both a bit and the
way I defined it initially operating
profit divided by assets they're ways of
saying before you consider taxes what
are your assets doing for you so once
again if this is a balance sheet this is
the assets
here are your liabilities debt could be
one of them but you know in general
these are your it could be a bunch of
other things you might owe other vendors
money or whatever then you have your
equity it's important when you ever talk
about any of these ratios you know
context are you trying to pass the CFA
exam or you're trying to impress your
MBA professor or you're trying to get an
intuition for helping you becoming a
better investor and I like to well you
know if you are investor you're probably
going to want to do the last of the
three and there are a is telling you the
return on assets telling you how good is
this company at getting a return out of
this thing right here I don't care how
they paid for it whether they had debt I
don't I don't want to think about are
they good at getting low interest I
don't I don't want to think about is
their CFO good at getting a better
interest rate than another CFO or are
they better at evading taxes than
another company all i care is the assets
that they have how good are they at
putting those assets to work and what
type of a return can they get so if i
calculate it using EBIT divided by
assets or operating divided profit
divided by assets if i use this is DS is
my metric for our away and i have what
company a has a 10% ROA and Company B
has a 15% ROA then I say you know what I
don't care whether B's guy is better at
getting a low interest rate or getting
some type of tax handout from the
government or doing something fancy with
with you know where he keeps his
subsidiaries I just want to know which
management is better at getting a return
out of these assets and these metrics
will tell you that right because it
tells you either how much operating
profit is being generated from here or
it could tell you how much II bit and
would in case an D bit might be a little
bit more informative because there might
be some of this income might be
generated from non operating assets so
you know some some maybe the company
holds some stock or it or it holds some
gold or something or it holds some
forward contracts to hedges exposure to
oil or foreign currency or something so
in general if you want to know what what
I think is the best ROA I would say it's
a bit over assets which is very close to
operating profit over assets and now you
say well Sal why are these other things
here and and why don't you like them as
much well net income over assets I think
the reason why that definition
because one net income it factors it
does factor in these things that frankly
I didn't want to think as much about but
in terms of you know when you talk about
return your what you get off the asset
you still are going to pay taxes on them
and if you do have some financing you
will be paying some interest on that so
that's why this comes out where they
actually just take the bottom line they
take the you know when people talk about
top but line and bottom line now you
know where those words come from top
line is revenue it's the top line of the
income statement and your bottom line
that's the bottom line of the income
statement that's where the word comes
from so that one definition takes this
and they divided by the total assets but
the reason why I don't like that the
reason why I don't like that is B it
doesn't separate out this definition
does not separate out that one company
might be better at evading taxes or
paying taxes and another company might
be better at somehow getting better
financing from the bank and that's not
what matters I care about the assets I
care just about the left-hand side of
the balance sheet while this is taking
into consideration some of the factors
on that side of the balance sheet for
example you could have company a let's
say you have two identical companies
this could be an interesting example you
have one company whoops
actually I just realized I'm out of time
I'll continue the example in the next
video and I'll explain a little bit
about the interest tax saving from
interest as well or sorry the tax
savings from from from from carrying
debt or from interest see in the next
video